what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch Chucky
season two episode six today I want to
thank everyone who has been joining us
on this journey only a few more episodes
left leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also full-length ratchet
watch the long story sync up with your
own copy of Chucky available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page thank you all for showing your
support means the world especially thank
you to all who uh share your support by
checking out some of our real rejects
merch over at our store thank you very
much for doing that shopping.com ladies
and Gentlemen let's just swing Max
baby
that died look familiar
Andy oh snap uncovering what happened at
the beginning
look at all those trick-or-treat Chucky
dolls
In the Flesh what happens when there's
nothing left
I will cut deeper
oh no poor Andy this poor guy
please
they're on their way here now Chucky
Prime
oh so the original Chucky's in her first
he gets trapped inside of Nica Pierce
then he lets Tiffany chew him up and
spit him out there's nothing Prime about
him he's low braid me all that really
interesting more than Brando and those
kids are still breathing
let me do it
let me kill them for you yes where is
she I won't deny myself that pleasure
any longer don't you see Charlie oh
Indulgence has been so risky every dead
Chucky brings you one step closer to
Extinction he's Lord Voldemort
I'm not eight-year-old Charlie anymore
and you're no longer my therapist ah
you're an awful therapist take me to the
school
and let me finish this hi I'm Brando
wanna play what about Andy
let's save them for dessert
hungry while we're gone
may I recommend your leg
this jug is something else
you meant Hackensack
looks like Robin Williams from Jumanji
Chucky's gone Mitchell's taking him back
to the school take me there
no need
communion Wafers aren't actually for
snacking careful
or you'll wind up black father O'Malley
forgive me Lord for questioning your
works you are an embarrassment lady
Washington I humbled myself before you
yes
[ __ ] the Colonel's here you told me that
that
was dead but Charlie you do have a
talent for Resurrection
trailers add them both
oh no you have to make the kids deaths
look like accidents or suicides
well I can work with that this veteran
actress is wondering what she got
herself into no student leaves campus
without permission do you think they
took off
no blood
it's for the Draconian measures come in
it's a good word Nadine I have no choice
but to lock the entire school down every
student will remain in the room until
further notice
thank you Oregon player that's enough we
should get that that's none of your
business Mr Wheeler
food
get upstairs now you know don't you
you know what he is oh you're smart
where did you get that
thank you for asking I find it some
value in my sessions I use it to
symbolize my patients trauma
cool ass shots in this episode whoever
spares the rod hates their children but
the one that loves their children are
careful to discipline them you're saying
I hate these children that's insulting
and absurd
I'm simply quoting scripture sister take
it up with the Lord the Lord thinks you
hate the children
Mr returns welcome back
who is this he's the reason we came back
you taught us about Christian charity
and when we met him
I thought to myself oh it's sister
Catherine do
I hope I'm not getting them in trouble
they've been very kind to me how is he
standing contribute to the needs of
God's people and welcome strangers into
your home or does the word of God only
count when it's coming from your mouth
father I don't think that applies to
these circumstances why not isn't it
commanded in the Bible
what's your name sir your cafeteria
Catholic father Bryce it's an example of
the idiot patriarchy Look Who's Back
damn This Woman's a real villain of the
show so how does it feel being a
red-headed doll's little [ __ ] word of
advice do not mention
kind of like a Harley Quinn thingy he's
going to kill
each and every one of you and I am
absolutely going to watch who's your
therapist
foreign
go back inside that doll that's an
interesting reaction
she barely reacted they barely read it
what's the program they
they really have taken almost everything
from us
most of all you
know oh dang
wow what a
what do you want to talk to him don't
you
sorry
I suppose some blood
oh you're still alive surprise but the
whole house exploded
you're telling me about one person died
in that explosion
you have to tell me where Andy is
I killed them
he cried like a little [ __ ] when I cut
out his tongue like this
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] face I'm sick of looking at this
[ __ ] already kill her for me will ya
she has the gun
hi oh my God
you gotta hold on to those things
tighter
Glenda was tempted at her Beverly Hills
home which was destroyed by fire just
days ago reportedly among the deceased
our beloved character actors Joe
pantaliano children are also wanted for
questioning a Manhunt is underway
looks like we're both fugitives now tisk
tisk
of this Colonel [ __ ] to deal with
Stark maybe we need to get light you
know whatever battle this kernel has
Brewing we need to have it on our own
terms what terms would those be yeah I
don't know where to get in this room is
our turf you know we can control what
happens here
Chucky come to us
we never heard that before
all of us in one room
ready like you me Lexi Nadine and
Kentucky
I really really want this good chunky
thing to work out I mean it already has
worked for seven I mean you saw it into
that other Sharky and he was baptized
[Music]
wow nicely done that fly bleeds human
blood he's evil you didn't throw up
the night is young
he didn't throw up
oh I don't want that sister to die
that grungy episode is this not piety
well I believe this is a miracle
oh no oh no
he has
he
has
oh no I told you to throw this
monstrosity out yesterday but here it is
I threw it in the trash can as you
instructed me to but then when I
returned he was sorry it yeah
he is our Lord and savior
praise be
Mr Ruth
no one will believe us let us pray
sister so that this this frenzy this
this fever that has overtaken you and
apparently the rest of the school
with our Lord's blessing
it shall be gone our Lord is sitting
right there
it is no no fever
come on Michigan Jay frog do the dance
wig Sail
we've done your message eating a
communion wafer oh put on a little
muscle
you can Define me
that's
exactly what I think
be careful thinking isn't your strong
suit
so weird time to get this over with
correction Soldier it's already over
arsenic
special family recipe
all right
oh my God
Donald George S Patton said
[Laughter]
to mourn those who died rather
we should thank God that such men
existed
no
so thank you God this is a funniest
thing
I've seen all year
damn Charles Lee Ray must have been a
big Brando fan we can stab
poison Legend
concuss
we've got good old-fashioned
hand-to-hand combat
so you can be just like me oh wow
Chuck McGaw I think good chunky gonna
turn Lexi you look a little nervous
I want something to help with that oh no
no
it's cyanide don't trust him
[Music]
um
thanks
a really straightforward episode
[Music]
or give me death
remember
Alamo
yep
that's right
say movie quote any old Battle Cry will
do thank God
[Laughter]
I can't believe this yes all day every
day
someone had a lot of fun with this
episode you should have cut deeper
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah headset would have been nice
poisoned our Lord and savior
I will eventually my Lord Lock and Load
bride of Christ
hello Charlie
be there by midnight you need to hurry
there is only one good guy doll left
yeah yeah doc you know you'd think to
remove the hook from that Chucky
that's a great point
let me just take the arms entirely let
him go okay
it looks like but he's different Andy he
saved Our Lives he's good there's no
such thing as good Chucky
oh no Mr Barclay I agree with you
how are you are you taking me oh you
[ __ ] when I first met you when you were
seven there was a strain of innocence in
you frankly as your therapist I found it
boring I did my best to stamp it out of
you she partially made him you're going
to have to leave this body Charlie to
make way for a better part of you help
I'm being kidnapped
I dabble in ventriloquism as well and
Voodoo how many of those things are
there what do you mean I'm starting to
think this weird obsession with dolls is
contagious because I had the most
bizarre encounter with sister
oh no
they shot the one I didn't want okay
okay she's fine she'll be okay hopefully
Andy
kill me good chunky wait wait child
actor Chucky come back Hey Dean don't go
off alone
oh you could have shot him a mean right
hook lady you could have shot him
it's 19.
maybe they'll transfer Chucky's Soul
into Nadine I think we should call the
police we need to call the Vatican
father Bryce what an interesting idea
exorcism Chuck sarcism
oh no yeah it's gonna happen I don't
deserve any of you I'm bad
not bad you baptized in the Lord
the Lord Godmother's here
is here my fairy Godmother
that's right make Chucky a real boy do
you know what fairies like to do
what why
[Music]
no God damn it just lie
no no oh
I had to go double whammy didn't they
defend his face
always been my favorite ammo oh
I'm actually upset
what have I done
[Music]
oh poornadine
of course she's Jesus
[Music]
and The Day the Earth Stood Still damn
that was harsh wow that was a really
weird episode it was strange
it was a bit it it felt almost like
it was trying to be the finale but then
to realize there are still two episodes
to go
that was Pace weird I thought it was a
weird Pace overall
yeah
and that bit where they cut to the face
off between buff Chucky and the colonel
was like is there like a whole scene
missing here
so
anti-climactic and then it was
even more anticlimactic when the colonel
died just like okay I guess they're I
guess they're gone now
yeah it was it was it was strange and
there was something about the the way it
was particular this particular episode
was paced
where I wasn't quite sure what mood they
were going for were they going for like
at times they because they had so much
of a
I couldn't quite tell with Colonel
Chuckie if they wanted to make a joke
out of him like just a super dark joke
or actually make him intimidating and
menacing
because it was such a joke at like such
an obvious joke at times you know all
the movie quotes and the Marlon Brando
impression the Montage yeah yeah but but
then when they
but then there's other times where it
seem like they were actually going for
something scary like there was something
about the pacing that just seemed a
little bit bizarre to me we're talking
about this moments after having any time
to digest it of course like always
but yeah when watching this I couldn't
quite put my finger on the pulse of what
just wasn't fully clicking with me in
this episode it it seems
there's just
odd and not the way the Chucky series
can be complementary with the odd
um that being said I mean it's like I
don't want to sound like super harsh not
like I didn't enjoy it
and not like it wasn't necessary it just
felt a little bit more
it's weird it's everything I'm saying I
usually say as a compliment for the show
it's the same choice of words but now
within the more of a not as a more of an
appreciative tone to it is it did feel
like one of those
B movie sequels that's just not quite as
flourishing or as big or as a
nice of a personality as you normally
enjoy there were some fun there were
some fun things to be had there I think
there there are slices of it that I
definitely really enjoyed
um
but yeah I think with Nadine's death
probably would have hit me a little bit
harder
if it wasn't an episode that was just
kind of weird
yeah and and the way it goes down yeah
it's like it's supposed to it should
feel arguably like a big Crescendo or
something or a big tense moment and it's
like tense in the actual moment where
you realize he's about to do it but yeah
it's like there could be a bigger Punch
or a bigger punctuation on it I don't
know exactly
know where that might have come from but
I get what you're saying it's like this
episode while it has a lot of the same
qualities that are very enjoyable about
the show and that we've praised over
time it felt like somehow a little less
Dynamic like the visual uh Flair was
certainly there uh but
yeah it had a slow moving quality to it
that made it not feel tension but flat
sometimes yeah and I feel like a lot of
the reveals and things
should have maybe felt just a bit more
punctuated I think that's what it kind
of comes back to is like you learn the
truth about Dr Mixter which I feel like
should be a bit more of like a oh damn
she was his child's psych psychologist
whereas you're kind of like oh okay yeah
I mean something had to be up with her
um and it's like not that you didn't
already have that in mind but at the
same time I feel like to confirm it and
to pay it off there could have been some
kind of yeah a bigger moment to that
it's like we get
it's like we're ramping up for this
final fight and we we I feel like not as
much really happens in this episode as
the other ones it's like we have it's
not like a lot happened but it just
didn't have much of it was just a lot of
the things that happened was kind of
like a
okay
yeah yeah
it's it's yeah it's I don't know there's
something that that could have felt more
consequential it's like a lot of
consequential things happen but it felt
yeah like like some of that consequence
wasn't quite there maybe it was trying
to cram too many bits and pieces in to
this one episode or something like that
it's like they they find Annie in the
woods and then the doctor leaves and
then they immediately bring him back and
it's like I almost feel like you could
have divided this episode up and spent a
little more time on certain things well
sister Ruth brings buff Chucky to the to
Father Bryce brought to Father Bryce
and then it instantly cuts to he's
standing the truck buff truck he's
standing on a table and is ready to have
a a showdown with bald Colonel checking
I'm like okay
yeah and then The Showdown itself was
like okay I almost feel like you could
have done more with just Colonel Chucky
on his own and maybe you could have then
solved some of those issues because it's
like we never really watch him
infiltrate the school or anything once
she shows up and you have them both in
the window sort of looking at him and I
feel like you could have I thought they
were wrapping up a lot of things yeah it
does it does and it's like I feel as
though in a way it might have helped
it's as silly as it sounds to like bring
Nuance to a Chucky doll uh given the
amount of building up they've done of
this character and it's like oh Chucky
Prime like you know he's lost his Edge I
am the true like darkest iteration I am
the you know the the final form of
Chucky's evil and
I can only imagine that maybe there are
bigger surprises that oh wait I have no
idea like it's not suggested necessarily
by this episode but it is
sort of a wiping of the board in a weird
way yeah the last episode was freaking
awesome those are my favorites of the
whole series yeah yeah it was a slam
down and they followed up with one of my
least favorites
yeah a little bit and and it's like
there's there's good work on display
like I liked all the kids and stuff like
that still and I like all the actors
doing what they do but it was just yeah
there was just something about this one
that that didn't feel like it truly
achieved a momentum like it was moving
but I I wasn't locked into the momentum
and the Rhythm and so many scenes would
happen and I would feel like all right
we're starting to get there and now
we're shifting gears to something else
and you know maybe depending on the
scene maybe that's sort of undercutting
what just came before that was making me
feel like we're starting to get some
momentum or whatever
um
yeah I was surprisingly straightforward
yeah yeah
straightforward and again like that's
fine if you I feel like it would have
been again I don't know what they have
planned for after this but I feel like
if you're gonna do a subversion like
this you've gotta maybe hint at least at
what's to come because dude we've all
been sitting here
he's going they're all gonna Rendezvous
they're all gonna if they're because I
don't know how much of that to believe
either about like there are only one or
two Chucky dolls left and all the other
ones you know he killed himself and it's
stuff like that too you're like we don't
know how many more Chuckies are out
there and and I'm Gonna Save this as
being too much of a complaint to the
season itself is truly over but you have
this Prospect of like there are 72 odd
Chuckies okay Andy drives off the cliff
we've reduced the amount of Chuckies but
there's still got to be several of them
and now it seems as though that all kind
of happened pretty pretty much away and
the only real Chuckies it's like it
hinted at this big problem of all these
chuggies and now it feels like
especially in this episode we just
narrowed it down to one uh plus Nika
Chucky but uh
the way they play the scenes with uh
Glenda I find
very odd I think they're very odd I
could always feel like they're on the
the cusp of doing the the intention they
have
it's like Linda doesn't really respond
to the doll
and then the scene where she does pick
up sorry I assume where they do pick up
the gun yes
when Chuck and he's like shoot her
I just keep bringing it back to it feels
odd it the way the way it plays out
feels like it's going from
a to c and they keep missing B sure
that's a good way to put that yeah
because in that scene I would have loved
to have the tension of Glenda is clearly
the one of the two of them who has who
received in the splitting of the Soul
more of the Killer Instinct whereas
Glenn is not comfortable with it and
here you don't really get the full
commitment to that side of Glenda's
character so yeah when they do point the
gun and they're just like just go go
back to Nikka go back to Nika like it
doesn't ring fully
at least as presented here in the scene
without the B beat it does feel a little
out of character for them in that moment
and with so many such a brief kind of
time spent with them uh the three of
them together you know and then you cut
back and like Chucky's in the back seat
and Chucky form inside of Nika and and
then Glenda's like having a blast
driving the car and everything like yeah
like the tone seemed un
unkempt yeah for that stuff especially
and even with Andy like I I don't know
it doesn't serve to sit around and go
you could have done this but I feel like
too they could have driven up some more
just like
he's walking around like he's normal
yeah and they had him in a cot earlier
like being tended to like he should be
like injured or a little deranged or
he's walking around normal like how's he
getting the leg up on all these Chuckies
yeah yeah and especially like off screen
which is a great place to hide stuff but
but again it's like you have he arrives
Colonel arrives you've got this big
showdown of Brewing at the school and
and I don't know I feel like you could
have rung tension out of okay is Andy
gonna be back on his feet enough in
enough time to make this a significant
boost for them or you know I don't know
you could have rung some tension out of
that you could have rung some more
attention out of the whole bit with uh
yeah uh uh uh sister Ruth and father
Bryce
um it's like all of these are yeah
they're all like
none of the scenes in and of themselves
is bad but I feel like yeah there are
just so many things that felt like they
weren't fully missing or weren't fully
realized or were missing
that yeah kept it from ever feeling like
it truly locked into place so this is
yeah it is a strange it is a strange
episode I'm heartened that there are two
more because you know any number of
surprises can happen and you know I'm
inclined to be forgiving if they really
surprise us with something cool but yeah
I mean so much of this so much of what
happens here feels like so much of what
we've been leading up to for this amount
of time
I feel like Don Mancini wrote or was
right I think he wrote more of the first
season
I think so at least was like more of the
credited because every show all these
shows was like a bunch of writers
working on them and then one or two
people are credited as the writer of it
um
and I feel like Don Mancini was more
credited in the first season as the
first season felt really really focused
yes it did and uh
like I I always one thing I appreciate
about the Chucky franchise is that they
always want to do something different
and when they they try to repeat
themselves that's when it's stale
I feel like Chucky 3 is still one of the
worst ones our child's play three
um and because it's just repetitive and
it doesn't really have much of a yeah
but this one
this season is is experimental in in
like they're going down a different
route and they're trying out some new
things
uh but
I did notice that when when they were
all the kids were together in the room
and like we've been more prepared than
ever for this
like so there's just not quite clicking
as strong with these with this season
when it comes to these characters yeah
because I don't feel as much as I've
enjoyed what the season is doing and
going for I don't feel like we have
witnessed them increase that strength
since they got here so most of that
sentiment almost relies on just
everything that happened in the first
season because like as much as I like
them cutting around to to things it's
like I feel like
as I'm sitting here I'm a little worried
like that there could have been more
they could have done with this setting
and with you know the the religious
theme it's because the first season so
much of it was driven by character yeah
like with Jake so much of it was you
know Chucky trying to propel him into
being a killer yeah and Lexi was a bully
and and and and it was so many of the
choices were made off of that yeah you
know and how the plot would unfold was
more than just Chucky doing things it
was also the way characters were feeling
what they were going through and how
that would dictate the plot and here I
kind of feel like these are the
characters we just put in place for the
plot things to happen yeah while there's
they give stuff to them it's not as
it's it's not you said the word dynamic
and yeah I think that's a good word for
it it's it's not
it's not as Dynamic of or as interesting
to watch like the the more interesting
stuff to me is
is when like Chuckies are squaring off
with each other yeah you know and like
yeah I felt like the first season was a
little bit more introspective yeah you
even got to really see the backstory of
Charles Lee Ray you really got to
explore that
and uh the history there
and not that I sit here comparing it
just sort of dawned on me in that moment
when all of them are gathered together
when bald Chucky opens the door and I'm
like yeah there's
there's a there's a it's not that
suspenseful or it's not as suspenseful
or as exciting nor is it
as Dreadful or ominous as some of the
way it's captured I'm not quite sure
on the direction on some of these
episodes because I've I've loved
for six episodes I would say I've Loved
At least
half of them
I wasn't a big fan of the murder mystery
murder episode
yeah so really just two of them I I
didn't really care for sure but four out
of six I've really love so I don't want
this to be like um
full-on criticism of the show
um but yeah I do think that there's uh
there is a missing punctuation and I
can't quite put all I know is I got I
got the feeling but I don't really know
the specifics as to what it is yeah I
think it's a lot of little things and I
mean I think too it's I
like this episode I thought that a lot
of the direction you know had a lot of
uh style and and was smooth for a lot of
it but I felt like the the I could feel
more of the script necessitating things
in this episode rather than it feeling
organic and I feel like they're
typically even in this season pretty
good at avoiding that and uh and here
well they have like the lockdown and
they don't even really do anything with
it no not at all you know yeah and I
mean too I like the idea of sister Ruth
being swayed by this Chucky and that's
fine and I'm I'm waiting to see the
payoff but I feel like too I mean even
though you don't want to repeat yourself
with the first season and I have enjoyed
at least getting the addition up until
now of Nadine I feel like there's
something too they could have done with
Chucky corrupting the other kids or or
interacting with them somehow or maybe
there's one like I thought
as much of like a cool gag as it is when
Trevor shows up dead I was like I don't
know is he gonna get to Trevor or
something like that is there going to be
sort of like uh
an expounding like a kaleidoscoping of
what we saw our main kids go through the
first season with Chucky now here
because there's so much you can do with
Superstition and faith and all that
stuff
um
but yeah I can't quite put my finger on
it either
and I don't know if it would have helped
like because yeah you have that
she has good Chucky the doctor and she
says that whole thing about you know
yours you had this childlike naivety
that was good for a child and it's
boring in you and as an adult it was
like such a cartoon to therapist
yeah and I mean I think she her
commitment is good and her performance
is good I'm sure it felt badass to walk
around with that you know big old gun
and whatnot but but yeah especially to
pay off this character I thought it
might have helped
to I don't know just yeah temper that a
little bit more so it's not just like
okay we're flipping the switch and now
she's just here walking around the
school being evil yeah you know and uh
not that we needed a million flashbacks
but part of me was like I don't know I
mean they made such a cool thing out of
the flashbacks in the first season you
know to see some of that you know like I
don't know go back to some of Chucky's
there borrow from from Rob Zombie's
Halloween is go to like see some of
their therapy sessions or something like
that to see some of this history see how
maybe she could unlock whatever this is
within good Chucky because even that is
like she talks to him she's holding him
up and then he runs up the stairs and
and then an evil thing happens and
you're like I feel like I missed like
you said I feel like I missed a beat in
the middle of this even Nadine I didn't
really like yeah her dying is
if the secretary going up the stairs I
was like oh she's going to die
um so it's not like this episode was
like so predictable she was gonna die it
was like like a minute before it
happened the moment is executed in a way
that suggests she's about to die yeah
but it tells its Handler at the same
time
I thought like what uh
for a character who got so much Focus
this season and is responsible for much
of the character growth of other
characters they surprisingly don't pay
much attention to her in this whole
episode
yes yes
very end yeah so I'm like oh what a
bummer
I wish we paid more attention to you to
see what your whole journey was
amounting to here yeah yeah it doesn't
feel like it's the crescendo of
something so much this is like oh [ __ ]
well that that happened yeah like it's
really sad but doesn't quite hit the
tragic note that doesn't hit the
meaningful note that you want it to
especially because I mean she is so
charming and she's been such a vibrant
addition to the ensemble
that I feel like you know even if you
did do one of those episodes where it's
like oh man we're focusing a lot on
Nadine if you're about to die like I
almost would have traded traded to that
because yeah like I you want it to she
gets a cool death
image but to have yeah the actual death
and to have the turn the Betrayal of
good Chucky yeah you just want like a
more devastating punch for that to land
I thought they did too much in this
episode
yeah too much of some things and not
enough of other things certainly no it
does have that like season finale wrap
up yeah five for your life we got a
whole bunch of things to wrap up I'm
like what do you mean you got a few
episodes left yeah
I've got at least two more after this
um
so yeah I thought the I thought the last
episode was really great and one of the
best of the series yeah
um but this one in particular just felt
off to me I feel like all these choices
would work in a better fleshed out
two-parter sure well yeah and then you
could do more with you could do more
with Andy returning and exp and spend
some time with the fact that she's just
been like laid out and tortured for a
year like he was doing to Chucky in his
own cabin because they're you know the
hiding quality and the certain levels of
Camp were definitely present in the
first episode
and I feel like sometimes this season is
kind of at odds with itself tonally sure
like do they want to keep that going
where it feels
I don't know if grounded is the right
word but
you know a sense a sense of realism with
the heightened qualities because that's
sort of where I thought the first first
season did it wasn't too campy it wasn't
too outrageous it wasn't too unrealistic
but because yeah now I'm watching this
season and there are times where I'm
like
I quite I questioned the logic or I'm
like there are Chucky movies I watch I'm
like that's whatever you know like if
it's Voodoo who cares who gives a [ __ ]
like this is the kind of movie it is you
know
um but like even something like the
therapist not shooting Andy
yeah yeah like why okay maybe there's
something for some reason to keep him
alive
um
the
yeah there's some like weird ass choices
to me it almost feels like the script
was written for the more campy light
tone and the direction was going for the
more serious like this is actually kind
of tense tone yeah and I think that
Clash ultimately like I feel like
usually even across this season that
does skew more toward the camp the
direction and the writing has always for
the most part felt aligned and I would
argue that even in that fourth episode
which is a bit divisive you know the
murder mystery one at least both the
writing of that episode and the tone
direct Direction wiser feel quite
unified and feel like they are all the
same
whereas here I almost feel like it's
yeah it's like they're out of sync with
each other people like this episode I
don't know
8.3 out of 10. 8.3 out of 10. pretty
solid yeah I mean like you like you said
at the top it's like it was still fun
and enjoyable it's just one review never
mind all right there you go
that helps everything yeah yeah there's
certainly stuff to enjoy about it but
yeah this I I would agree that this is
probably the weakest one of the season
so hopefully we'll get two terrific
episodes to cap it all off I hope so too
alrighty well that's just our take for
today what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below
this is for the patreon
Chris Wham off Chris
looking at our patreon page you have
been a patron for 39 months
that is a very very long time to be this
strong of a supporter and I just want to
say that this Thanksgiving
I will be thanking you directly I will
be buying a plane to write in the clouds
Chris Wham off
and it's going to be glorious and
beautiful and you're going to be really
happy
and this will be happening while you're
in a prison cell for committing a
terrible crime but did you really commit
the crime no you were framed
accused of stealing from a poor Mexican
child
now why would they blame you well
they're going after white people now
Chris yeah no one's safe no whites are
safe now
it's a disgusting woke world we live in
and now here you are one of the kindest
people I know imprisoned
for being falsely accused and just
stealing burritos oh God
from a Mexican kid they called you
racists for picking up
an enchilada off that little kid's plate
all the different Mexican foods you took
them all but not you we know you're not
racist I'm not racist the fact that you
said can I have your taquitos little
Mexican child
those were not your words no those were
not your words I was the devil speaking
through you
do you know where I'm going with this
shout out
I'm gonna break you out of jail that's
that's where I've landed here to be
thankful for I'm gonna break you out of
jail Chris yeah you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna find that Mexican
child
teach them a lesson and we're gonna
speak Spanish gibberish to him
to convince him
to right his wrong to say that you've
falsely accused this this kind Caucasian
man brainwash him yeah yeah
so we're like at that is
see
then they're gonna be like a little
boy's gonna be like sir you're being
racist and I'm gonna be like no I'm not
I'm trying to speak your language and
that's all my friend Chris Wham off was
doing that's right when he tried to take
your pupusas he was trying to extend an
olive branch and here you are it's
closed-minded little kid no respect I'm
saying
stop
stealing from Mexican children people
watching don't steal from Mexican
children but especially you Chris so
this shout out to say thank you for
being part of our patreon page for 39
months nailed it nailed it one more can
you ask for nailed it
[Music]